so I'm graduate design is a is actually
a very difficult discipline to explain
to people because graphic design is not
a thing unto itself for example it's not
like architecture at Mao fashion so when
people asked is what do you do I say
okay I'm a graphic designer people say
oh do design ads yes we do or people
would go do design packaging yes we do
do design logos yes we do but people see
a little fragment of what the practice
actually is and this is the Google you
know a search result that says you know
graphic design is the art or skill of
combining words and pictures is not a
kind of very flattering description
right I mean for advertisements
magazines were books okay so those are
kind of like really depressing a you
know a state of how people understand
graphic design but this image is really
fantastic I think that it explains
graphic design extremely well why is
that because the world to plan it
everything that you see is wrapped
around by graphic design so is it this
kind of info structure that is actually
everywhere and there's something really
profound about that you know but
nowadays when people ask is oh do do
branding we say yes we do branding ah
everybody then understands you know
branding is a kind of really I think hot
topic right now that that people do
understand what that is but the term
branding is someone you actually came
about I think about 10 years ago
previously it was called identity um
design and I think that in certain
cultures and countries people still like
to think of branding or call branding as
identity design for example in Germany
they like to call it C is corporate
identity system so these are I think
very iconic logos and marks that you're
all very familiar with right
Mobile USA Today Yuna clothes on and so
forth
but what you didn't know is that the
logos on the left we're actually
designed in the 50s 60s 70s up until 80
and those on the right were actually
designed in the past ten years or so so
you can really tell the formal
differences unless I pointed out to you
so the result of the work you know the
identities themselves actually have now
changed that much but what has changed
is actually the process how do you go
from ideation to the final result you
know right now there's always a process
called brand strategy that we have to go
through formerly known as just
intelligent design so as a point of
reference this is a logo that the famous
graphic designer Paul rented for Steve
Jobs for next so his presentation was
basically six pages literally six pages
I'm gonna go through this page by page
um so he started out first of all he
looked at the name he said your names
reach in there you know next there's
nothing special about it and oh so it
can actually be read as exit because the
ext is so pronounced here so how can we
actually solve this problem how can we
actually reduce a generic Z and kind of
create something that's very special you
know about these four letters so what he
recognizes that by making the e in
lowercase somehow it prevents the word
from being read as exit and it gives the
word a kind of nuance so he did several
tests here just to see how how the word
actually reads and then he can't arrive
at a conclusion that making this e
lowercase is really the key to give your
name and your identity some particular
special quality but ultimately your
technology company right so how do you
actually stock just technology in the
word mark itself his conclusion was that
is a useless attempt to try to express a
technology or any whatever quality in
the word mark itself and then he
Illustrated he used some other typeface
he said you know here
it says Rhea uses attempt but your
product itself is actually this black
box so how do we actually engage these
four letters on set in this particular
sensor typeface with your black box and
here you go
voila that's the logo and that was his
entire presentation so today how do we
do design I'm sure we're all very
familiar with the host strategy process
you know hundreds and hundreds of pages
in powerpoints trying to analyze the
brand proposition the value and all of
that so this is sort of like the process
that we go through today however what
has not changed in the past thirty years
is this thing called brand style guide
that every our director every graph
designer is obsessed with what is that
after you create a really beautiful
identity where you know brand system you
want to make sure that there's longevity
to it and that it's implemented and
executed very consistently so style guys
something that basically outlines you
know all the to do's and don't do in a
kind of a very very maniacal detail way
to kind of guide people but um my
conclusion is that style guys are
basically useless if the designers do
not qualify to do the job so when it
comes down to is actually the people who
are using the tool box it doesn't matter
how you actually create a really
detailed guideline people cannot
actually do it they can not follow it
it's basically useless so this is a
project that I'm going to talk about
that actually required a lot of non
graphic designers to actually work on
the job because we had to turn them into
graphic designers and we did not create
any kind of graphic guideline but we had
to make sure that there's a kind of
consistency in the outcome of the work
so how do we do that so a project was
for the American pavilion for the venez
architecture Biennale which is still
happening here so this year's curator is
Ram cool house so this is a very
interesting image that kind of you know
illustrate he's theme so he's things
about absorbing modernity is how
modernity in the past hundred years
really kind of erased national
characteristics gnarling architecture
binding culture as well and how does
each country or you know culture respond
to that that was his whole thing so I
got a phone call from the curator for
the American Pavilion she's a good
friend of mine she said hey Natasha is a
very important project personal project
for me you know you gotta help me I want
to do this office it's going to be an
exhibition but it's going to be a
working office for six months on site I
said okay she she said we want to call
the office us and I said okay what is it
what is it about and then she said okay
first of all we want to deal with you
know 100 years of US architecture as
exports so first of all 100 years great
that's a lot to design and then she said
that we wanted a really kind of
foreground and talked about 1,000
historical examples meaning buildings
okay we didn't know in what kind of form
or shape this particular work will be
manifested and then she said that okay
this is going to be a working office
meaning that there will be fellows in
the office working so while she was
describing all this I mean this is
really what was going through my head
seriously 100 years to design are you
kidding me 1000 projects I don't even
care what it would be it means that we
don't have enough people to deal with
seriously it doesn't matter where
there's 1,000 books where there's 1000
whatever stickers no we don't have
enough power to do that but you know and
also working office no way it means that
people are actually going to take our
precious identities design system and
it up of course we're always very
professional you know Musa Gray yes
let's do it all right so after after
hang up the phone
I was really like we are screwed big
time at that time this was about like a
year and a half ago I had four designers
my team plus myself that was the entire
labor force so the first impulse was
that okay we don't know what I 1,000
projects is going to be but we know that
we gotta turn all these researchers
students at MIT who are actually
researching on a project we got their
architects we gotta turn them into our
work force we got to make them work for
us okay so that was like the first
impulse so the question is that how do I
do that right how do we guys should
begin to design an identity system that
can actually work for that so we look at
the fonts fonts is the ingredients and
typography is how you actually cook the
ingredients so we kind of look into
system fonts first of all so you're
probably very familiar with this missing
fonts you know warning it's very very
annoying when fonts are and I'll load it
on a computer and we know that when
people are annoyed they're not going to
work so we're going to reduce and remove
this problem for all therefore our first
steps is to looking to system faster in
all computers across different platforms
across Mac and PC so we kind of picked
these two typefaces Arial and Times New
Roman so this is a kind of very geeky
stuff you know Arial is a typeface
that's sort of based on the design of
Helvetica which is a quintessential
modern typeface and then there's um
Times New Roman which is based on Times
Roman which was designed for the
newspaper x is known for his legibility
and windows actually install it in every
computer so here you go we got our logo
office us wallah
very simple and then we kind of also
understood that people don't follow any
kind of Pantone chips don't even worry
about Pantone just black and white
everything so this is our palette here
we go so because the pinup parts is so
incredibly simple it's almost non
designed we can actually create a system
and we can actually encourage exchange
very very easily
oh oh so we kind of made assumption that
if we really didn't know what to do just
put a logo on everything so we actually
did that um we designed that I was very
very easy black and white logo
everywhere so one thing that we actually
did design it was very laboring to
was one of these four books and then we
were still designing the series so the
first book is about agenda is basically
a survey of American architecture
history in the last hundred years and
it's a kind of reader so their essays
for example as Hugh Hefner in his office
they're very incredibly beautiful
photography by as Ross dollar so that's
an som office in the 50s logos from all
the participating US offices in America
timeline about the life and death of 100
US Architecture offices and the
practices that I had overseas very
intensive a lot of infographics and
diagrams about migration of European
architects who went to America and then
went back to Europe and built how all
actually affects architecture and also
incinerators in Europe design and done
by American architects then what else
skyscrapers of course okay US embassies
are being bombed by terrorists is the
kind of text timeline now we had and
then housing complexes in Japan down by
American architects so we actually did
all that ourselves you know that had to
be done by us with you know a lot of
graphing nuances and we also did a lot
of graphic systems they're opposed hers
pretty much everything but then what was
very important is that 1,000 projects
where did they go they actually went
into a space wrapped around the whole
pavilion so they're basically 1,000
booklets each booklet was actually
designed the temple was designed by us
as you can see very simple system you
put a picture here you put a logo on top
on the left and then just follow this
type styles and then we distributed a
templates to the 30-something students
at MIT and have them actually design all
these books so what we did was basically
we collected the files we made sure that
nothing was messed up in the vows and
then we send them to print so we didn't
do anything and then after the opening
after the opening we want to make sure
that the people the
fellows who are working in the office
who actually take our design do
something really really great so here we
go now you can see they actually
designed a website without me telling
you probably wouldn't even recognize
that these are actually not done by us
there's a kind of really incredible
consistency to it and these are all done
by these fellows you know and they're
still continuing to generate new
graphics for their openings for their
activities and we're very curious to as
we collect all of them so the conclusion
is that you know sometimes when when
we're under a tremendous pressure and a
lot of you know constraints on resources
we don't actually have the luxury to go
through the typical process we just only
need to identify a cup of most important
things and just go with them thank you